e
okay good morning everyone the time
being 10:17 I'm going to open the exec
585 and um so over the
past week or so uh representative uh
Ames and representative spillsbury have
worked on an amendment to SP
585 and
um right now representative spillsbury
is in a senate uh hearing introducing a
Senate bill um so we will start with um
representative Ames to kind of tell us
with okay I'll give this a try
um this is all uh in in many ways quite
straightforward um but let's see if we
can uh walk through it the uh the bill
concerns the use of a property the
application of a pro property lean for
unpaid um or un returned to Dr taxes uh
and this is the meals and rooms tax
we're talking about um in the previous
version of the
bill uh the uh discussion that we had uh
sort of centered on the wording that uh
identified the people who might be
subject to the lean and um and I think
we all felt that it was uh pretty fuzzy
and uh and might catch up some people
who would find themselves uh um having
property that was now subject to a lean
even though they'd had no involvement
whatsoever in the business activity that
uh led up to this um so uh we worked uh
together to try to uh fix that um and
what you have in front of you it's
Amendment 2024 1796
H is uh represents the our work
product um what we uh we we've turned
this around from the concept of uh
people who had a managerial capacity in
a organization that was uh the that was
uh uh collecting this tax and not
returning it to the
Dr
um and felt uh as we thought about it
that that wasn't the uh right Focus
managerial capacity was a concept that
might pick up uh uh Frontline managers
in a Burger King for example um and uh
that had no no relationships at all to
the financial flows in the business so
um so the new language uh abandons the
concept of managerial capacity of of an
organization and focuses on the uh the
responsibility the people who have
responsibility for the ta ta for the tax
so you see that language in in
bold
um starting at line
14 and we're defining operator to
include any
person who has actual or constructive
managerial or custodial responsibility
for the collection and transmission of
attacks subject to demand under this
chapter so that's that's the core of
this thing and uh people in in with that
kind of
responsibility uh would be subject to
the uh the lean and then an additional
sentence relates to we discussed sort of
passive owners uh wanted to be sure that
passive owners that uh have no no um
meaningful relationship to the
activities that uh are involved in
collecting and holding uh tax uh
revenues um would not be caught by this
and so um so a mere ownership interest
shall not be considered to sufficient
Nexus is the language that gets rid of
that problem I don't think it's actually
NE necessary one could have this bill
without that it's just making explicit
that that won't uh won't do do the trick
in terms of being subject to lean just
because you have an ownership interest
let's say you're a uh uh in a
partnership and uh you're just a uh
General partner without
managing responsibilities um that those
people would not be ens snared by this
and uh then uh we also thought we should
make explicit that the Department of
Revenue Administration could uh could
lay out in rules uh the criteria that
might apply that would that they would
apply to um discern
which uh situations met the standard
that's in this Bill and which do not and
U that picks up on the list that was
passed To Us by Dr last time um of uh
the kinds of situations that should be
subject to um to uh s subject the person
to uh the the
lean um so that's that's basically
that's the best I can do with it and uh
I uh I think uh both uh representative
spillsbury and I feel good about our
interactions on this uh this bill we
think we've come to a good result and
our chair uh shephered us as we did this
so thank you for that and uh that's
where it lies and now we'll find out
whether we did indeed did did a good job
or not by your reaction thank you thank
you representative Ames I think um
you've spelled it out nicely and um
as you know I saw the emails going back
and forth between you and spillsbury and
representative spillsbury and um and I
think you guys really um did a lot of
work and and came to a good conclusion U
yes representative
fellows um yes I just have a question um
my one of my concerns was that a hired
manager somehow might be held
responsible and when I look at this it
seems like that would Prelude that from
happening do you do you think that's
correct I didn't I didn't hear the
adjective you put on the manager what
kind of manager h a hired
manager you know everything
turn everything is determined by what
responsibility the person has is not not
the title that will um determine that so
I can't answer your question without
knowing what the hired manager was hired
for
and and if I remember one of the issues
last time was whether a member should be
held responsible or not and I think the
the nice thing about this new language
is if you are a passive member you would
not be held responsible but you could
still be a quote member but if you've
got sufficient um managerial capacity or
um what's the word authority over this
then you could be held responsible so
this new
language potentially allows a member to
be um held responsible and I think that
was what um we were trying to get to so
uh representative ol I see you and thank
you Mr chair um and following up on
representative fellows the determination
would have to be made by DR Dr first
regarding construed managerial or
custodial responsibility before an
action could take place and those
specific terms are already predetermined
in G in the broad body of uh black
letter
law
so it's it's it's a narrow field because
it's already predefined an existing law
representative Southworth yes just a
comment I want to go back to the
testimony from Dr um Al Leen is Al
lean's definitely a last resort and they
try many steps ahead of that which means
it shouldn't be a surprise uh if it
finally gets to the lean level also
um this tax is collected by the business
for the state the money never really
belongs to the business in any way any
part of the process so again it
shouldn't be a surprise that this money
is only to be delivered to the
state all right representative uh Aly
yes I think we're not in executive SE
session yet are we we are we are um can
we call uh we have represent brury back
uh can we call up the people from
restaurant and lodging and the people
from Dr to just say whether this
works
sure
yes chair uh just in case you haven't
noticed on page two on the back there's
a very good
explanation as to who's responsible and
the last line actual or constructive
managerial or custodial responsibility
for the collection and transmission of
the tax I think that really says it all
perfectly thank you thank
you um yeah so this time I I'd like to
call up Dr and
um one or all of you whoever feels that
this good morning for the record
Jennifer Ramsey tax policy council with
TR and good morning assistant
lir could you spell your first name is o
r a last name is l e capital m e r
e thank
you and I wanted to take a moment to
introduce Miss Jennifer Ramsey our tax
policy Council replacing Mr Kean
Wong
okay all right so I know that you just
got this amendment um I don't know five
minutes ago uh do you have any initial
thoughts on
this thank you Mr chair we did have a
chance to review the amendment we
appreciate the thought that went into
this I think this amended language
addresses our concerns and we appreciate
the rul making authority to further
flesh out the definition um and so I I I
think drra would support the statute as
representative spillsbury I know you
didn't have the advantage of hearing
representative Ames I think he did a
good job describing it is I'm confident
that representative ases did a good job
thank
you anybody have any other
questions
Dr
rest okay okay thank you thank you very
much all right restaurant and lodging
we'll
see good morning uh Henry veu from uh
Shen fin Capital group representing the
New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association and uh I think Mike and I
learned something this
morning and what we learned is that we
should have had representative Ames and
spillsbury draft the bill for us in the
first
instance no it uh it meets the intent of
what we're trying to do that's great
thank you question represent fellows so
I'm going to ask the same question I
asked before do you think that this um
the way this is written will mean that
the responsibility won't be put on
somebody who who is just a hired
employee and not part of the LLC
partnership yeah I would agree with
representative am's response it really
depends on what the responsibility are
of that person if that person's
responsibilities include preparation and
submission of the tax then um they would
uh be caught in the web but um that that
was the intent of it all along
so followup so even if that person is
just a hired employee right if they're a
hired employee with no involvement in
what this bill uh addressing then they
wouldn't uh they wouldn't uh be uh
assessed the text
she
oh
okay representative yeah if I could just
try to put that in uh basic English on
if you are working in a convenience door
and um you are a hired employee and you
are collecting the tax as part of the
price
on but on it is the man
the real manager who collects all the
money that you've collected and divides
it up into tax and and um money for uh
profit then then on you aren capable of
lean yes represent fellows so I think
part of the the problem is that I come
from a perspective of financial
accounting for nonprofits and
particularly school districts and that
even though you have a financial manager
who determines H how you know
distribution of money to pay your
obligations which would include this
there is somebody in case of uh school
districts in the state board that has to
approve those um dispersements of funds
and so to me the school board is
equivalent to the Partnerships and so
that's that's what I'm trying to get at
that you can't just you know because the
bookkeeper doesn't you know cut checks
or you know approve you know things for
payment
the bookkeeper doesn't do that somebody
I would think at the partnership level
would is that correct or corre not
correct so that would exclude somebody
who's simply an employee
correct thank
you yes and that's why the the terms
constructive management because that
wouldn't be constructive just because
all set okay any more
questions comments okay
um I was about to say the clerk will
call the role but we don't have a motion
yet we don't have a
motion um so U representative uh Ames
and spsb do you want to fight it out to
motion I trust I'll have a immediate
second so do you have a motion
representative spillsbury I move uh uh
OTP on HP 585 and when given a chance
well first oh I'm sorry yes
good SP 585 and I second
that SP 585 this was
OTP for for the bill itself right yes am
seconds it
okay and now you have to do the and I
will further motion move um o uh aop
yeah any would you like to speak to your
motion representative spillsbury very
briefly thank you for taking it on in my
absence um I think what
we detected that the Senate bill sent to
us had an important purpose but didn't
go far enough and we've now elaborated
on it and clarified it and I think this
is just a dramatic step forward I think
when you reflect back on what the
current law says without this bill as
amended we cannot let it stay it it
places too grave a risk in the wrong
place so I urge otpa thank you any
further
discussion okay see N I will ask the
clerk to call the role uh this is on
Amendment 1796 H representative duet yes
representative erery yes uh
representative Hill didn't show up did
he representative spillsbury
yes representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes representative
ORS yes representative rord yes
representative ner yes representative
Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
repres shambre is not here correct
correct uh representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes represent
elberger yes representative leapley yes
Andi representative Smith is not here so
yes okay that's 17 yes three not is it
voting okay the now the amendment on the
floor I'm sorry the um motion on the
floor now is out to pass as
amended is there any discussion on
that seeing who's making the motion uh
and who's
I have to fill out the form that's all
okay chair yes so while we're waiting on
the clerk I'd like to say this is like
the cleanest piece of legislation I've
seen in two years that I've been here I
just like you guys nailed it so done
second shall I commence the clerk shall
call the role thank you this is ought to
pass as amended for 585 FN
representative duet yes representa oler
yes representative Hill is not here
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes representative
ORS yes representative rosit yes
representative ner yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
uh
shanberg is not here not here he's away
for two weeks okay I had this in the
wrong
place okay representative
fellows yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes represent
Smith is not here uh the chair
yes I Mis counted
wrong okay representative ducet one
representative allery 2 spillsbury 3 PL
4 sod5 Ora six R 7 uh eight that's what
I did wrong
uh not and then 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
so it's 170 three not
voting okay the vote being 17 to Zer do
I have any objections to consent seeing
calendar and representative spillsbury
okay I'm going to close the exec session
on uh SP
585 and that concludes our bills um I
didn't look this morning but looking
yesterday this was the only one left um
and I don't believe there's any new ones
so U next up is going to be the uh
reports from the Senate any bill that
they um
amended um is going to come back to us
as a senate report that
um the the house bills that is that uh
we will have to decide whether we concur
with the change we don't concur or we
don't Concur and want a committee of
conference report um so I have I have
five of them now um three of them are
second committee I just got them
literally half an hour ago so I need to
talk to the on since we are the second
committee on three of them I need to
talk to the chair uh two of them are not
um um so anyways that's that's the
status on that and uh we'll keep you uh
updated on that so now that um our uh
house bills are done we can start we're
going to have a update from uh Dr as
well as Chet and I think we'll lead off
with Chris will give us a little